hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
near the end of the second section of
Kant's groundwork of the metaphysics
morals he discusses the freedom of the
will and in fact one of the things that
he wants to tell us at that point is
that the freedom of the will which is a
very important doctrine running through
many moral theories is not something
that we can empirically verify or
experience but rather something that
must be as he says presupposed or
sometimes it's called posited for outs
cos x in in german and why is this the
case why on the one hand do we have to
assume it or to have it there in
whatever account we're going to have as
human beings of morality of all these
sorts of things and on the other hand we
can't actually experience it and thereby
refer to that experience by way of proof
at the same time that's a great question
so he starts out by talking about the
will itself and he says that the will as
a faculty is a type of causality that
belongs uniquely to living rational
beings so Kant is not going to talk
about the will as something that say you
know any old thing happens to have for
instance a chalkboard or even a
cockroach or you know an amoeba or
something like that he is confining this
to human beings and whatever might else
be rational now notice that he calls it
a type of causality we're going to
explore that very important notion in a
moment he says it's a causality that
belongs to living rational beings and
freedom is a property of that causality
so freedom is something that we can say
precisely about that causality so we've
got will which is a kind of causality
and then there is this kind of causality
here which is free causality we might
say so it's a property
of that causality that is the will that
it can be efficient that it can produce
effects without other clauses
determining it in earlier ways of
thinking about this for example
Aristotle talks about you know human
beings being a self moved mover right
with taught that that notion is being
rolled into this this notion of
causality I caused my will to determine
itself the will is reflexive it bears
upon itself it can determine itself
regardless of what other outside factors
are impinging on it Const by the way is
not denying that we have all sorts of
things you know suggesting to our will
which way it ought to turn or what
object we ought to prioritize over
another that's that's a guarantee that's
granted that's part of our experience
but he's saying that the will has this
property the property of freedom namely
that it can it can actually set all
those aside if it chooses to and say
nope I'm going to do this instead and so
the will has what we might call a
certain spontaneity or even at this
point we might say arbitrariness to it
we can contrast this against what Kant
calls physical necessity which is when
objects simply behave the way they do
because they are following causes and
effects and laws like you know for
instance gravity I dropped this it's got
a fall right there's no choice about it
one way or the other
now I of course did have a choice about
whether I drop it or use that as an
example and you might say well wait a
second dr. Stadler what about your brain
States and you know all sorts of other
interesting regularities that we can
talk about maybe you know the laws of
Association in psychology whatever it is
that you want to put out there right we
in fact about human beings being
determined not just by you know physical
interactions but also by cultural and
social interactions which at the same
time can
be reduced to loss well can't would say
the will is also able to determine
itself abstracting or bracketing or
presenting from those causes as well so
if you know some psychologist has worked
out or some neuroscientist has worked
out some law that says dr. Sandler must
do this at this moment I can still say
no not going to do that going to do
something else
it goes beyond this however so and this
is where causality and a very short
analysis of causality comes in that
that's quite important so Khan says the
causality involved laws that's why it's
intelligible to us to begin with if we
didn't have laws if we weren't able to
say that the cause in some way
necessitates or produces the effect then
we wouldn't be able to make any sense of
that we wouldn't use these terms like
cause and effect we wouldn't put
together a coherent world and context
that causality is something that we
can't help but you know see out there in
the world now the question is what about
our wills are those caused or are those
just effects of other causes we've
already talked about this the will has a
freedom and spontaneity to it now the
question is whether the will just does
what it does sort of arbitrarily you
know in a veal kerlick in German will
like actually arbitrary contingent way
or whether there is a different kind of
law that that's working here so freedom
does not depend on physical laws as a
matter of fact it's able to set them
aside right however Kant's says that
does not mean that it is there by law
list it would actually be incoherent if
it were totally without any regularity
whatsoever that could be could be
observed right or understood at least
conceived so it does have was what kind
of laws well those can't be physical
laws because then it would be dependent
upon them it can't even be like
psychosocial law
however else you want to think of that
it can't be dependent upon say
neuroscience to use our latest thing
that everybody's you know wild about
it's going to solve all of our problems
from a Countian perspective no freedom
has laws but those are not laws
dependent upon those sorts of things
physical necessities however they may be
parsed out and understood into the
social and cultural it gives itself laws
and what do those laws look like well
unsurprisingly these are going to be the
kinds of laws that you know can fit for
example constant systems on universality
you know for example the categorical
imperative in its first formulation that
we should act always on the maximum that
can be willed at the same time to be a
universal law of nature right those are
the kinds of laws that actually do in
fact make us free according to Kant he
goes a little bit further in telling us
that the freedom of the will must be
understood not only as belonging to us
but belonging to all rational beings and
now you might say well how can we
possibly know that I mean we can't even
empirically experience our own freedom
of the will in ourselves how are we
supposed to do that in other people
unconscious look this is not something
that needs to be empirically noted or
proven or anything along those lines
right instead he says we have to assume
it or we have to postulate it we have to
think it we cannot actually make moral
decisions without having this in the
background and now through our analysis
we have brought you know the free will
or freedom of the will to light as
something that we do in fact have to
ascribe to everybody now notice what
is saying and notice what he is not
saying he is saying that all human
beings by virtue of being rational are
free he is not saying that we do not
have as human beings living in a world
and in culture all sorts of you know
messages that can act as causes upon us
however we do not have to be with a
sense of you know absolute necessity
determined by them there is a
possibility of deciding for what is
moral and that's all that he's holding
out for here he's not saying that
everybody will act in a moral way or
realize what is moral or choose what is
moral it's always possible precisely
because the wheel is free for it to
throw away that very freedom but
according to Kant the wheel is indeed
free and here is how it works
you